hey guys it is the 14th of January today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games bunnies Nintendo Direct
was a thing that happened today and
here's a rundown of all the good stuff
nintendo announced a brand new entry
into the Fire Emblem series which will
be coming to 3d app although we haven't
yet heard anything more about the game
or when we can expect it the next wave
of amoebas also known as those little
plastic figurines which are occasionally
wildly expensive have also been revealed
the new characters available in
miniature form will include Robin
luchina pac-man warrior yes and
charizard there's also a super mario
brothers line of amoebas coming soon
featuring the characters yet expect
nintendo are also kicking off a new
strategy that will let you download wii
games onto your wii u those include
super mario galaxy to punch out and the
hard to get metroid prime trilogy all
retailing for twenty bucks although
there will be ten dollars on their
respective weeks of release if hardware
is your thing then you nintendo 3ds XL
is set to arrive in the US and UK on
februari 13 and it'll run you two
hundred dollars u.s. there appear to be
no present plans to have the smaller non
XL version brought to the US though they
will make their way to the UK in on
Nintendo news info on the next total war
game to be released by Creative Assembly
has leaked and it seems were in for a
warhammer themed title the new game
entitled total war war hammer is set to
adopt the Warhammer series's fantasy
setting and will also feature
traditional elements of strategy and
military tactics that the Total War
series is known for publishers sager yet
to comment on the leak which was
uncovered in an art book for the Total
War series slated for release on January
23 Sega also yet to comment on why they
didn't just name it took Warhammer if
you're still tossing up between the ps4
and the xbox one there's no a way that
you can have both in one box for some
reason Eddie Derek who is also known for
such creation
as the playstation 4 and xbox one
laptops has now created what he's
calling the play box which combines both
consoles into a 22 inch laptop
abomination Derek said the console is
made to order and he doesn't intend to
make more unless people want them since
they're expensive to make and take a lot
of time let me know down in the comment
if you be keen on an all-in-one ps4 and
Xbox one and why or why not you can also
head to gamespot for more stories on
things like a Majora's Mask theme 3d yes
and all the celebrities that attended
minecraft craters not just housewarming
party that is it for me today let me
know what you thought of today's news
and I will catch you again same time
tumor